qui ont proposé merci madame là par
l'état monsieur julien dive merci
monsieur le président depuis début
octobre des manifestations mobilise les
forces de l'ordre mais pour une fois ces
femmes et ces hommes ne sont pas là pour
encadrer les cortèges
non tous sont là pour défendre leur
profession et défendre l'état de droit
qu'il incarne
chaque semaine entre nous vous
interpelle ici sur ce phénomène et vous
nous dites toujours la même chose
vous allez me répondre que des effectifs
ont été supprimés dans le passé vous
allez me répondre que votre plan prévoit
un budget supplémentaire ça ils me
répondent que je devais regarder et il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît en écho de la
question moi ce que je peux entendre
c'est une vision de l'avenir et des
perspectives que l'état offre à nos
forces de l'ordre au commissariat de
saint quentin
on m'a récemment raconté ce fait un
jeune homme de 15 ans arrêté pour méfait
a giflé l'un des policiers qui le
ramener chez lui
la réponse judiciaire n'a été que le
rappel à la loi
où est le respect de l'uniforme à
travers une personne qui n'est pas
respecté à travers un et formes qui ne
plus respecter c'est l'autorité de
l'état qui n'est plus respectée une gif
c'est la première marche de l'escaladé
de la violence qui nous mène au drame de
viry châtillon
vous avez annoncé un plan gouvernemental
mais avec vous annoncez vos chiffres ou
ne fait que gérer les symptômes et non
les causes ces policiers gendarmes qui
n'ont pas peur de se mettre en danger
pour les autres équipes
leurs familles le matin pour faire 10 12
heures de travail heureusement qu'il ne
s'arrête pas à 35 heures par semaine
chacun d'entre eux mérite le respect et
la reconnaissance du rôle fondamental
qu'il joue pour maintenir la sécurité et
l'état de droit
ils nous viennent en aide nous protège
qui les aide qui les protège
concrètement comment votre plan sera
décliné en dehors de la région
parisienne dans nos commissariats de
villes moyennes dans nos zones
périurbaines et rurales
certaines polices municipales sont même
mieux équipés que la police nationale il
faut bien le dire
nous devons réformer le modèle actuel
reconnaître le travail fourni par les
forces de l'ordre et leur faire
confiance et une priorité les
manifestations continuent et vous serez
interrogées chaque semaine tant que le
problème persistera tant que nos forces
lors nous pourrons pas bien si on
allègera les termes que bernard
cazeneuve le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député merci de votre
question merci de m'annoncer toutes
celles à venir
ça me permettra de me préparer et de
vous répéter inlassablement la même
chose parce que ce que nous faisons pour
donner des moyens aux forces de l'ordre
c'est un travail qui s'inscrit dans la
durée
parce que depuis des décennies ces
forces de l'ordre ont été laissées en
déshérence que les investissements
concernant la police nationale et la
gendarmerie ont diminué de 15% c'est
vrai monsieur le député je suis désolé
de vous le dire mais si l'on veut avoir
des forces de l'ordre qui sont en
situation qui souhaitent en situation
d'accomplir leur mission
il ne faut pas éradiqué leurs moyens
mais ford leur donner les moyens
d'accomplir leur mission et c'est la
raison pour laquelle au terme de ce
quinquennat nous aurons créé 9000
emplois et augmenté de 15% les crédits
de la police et de la gendarmerie
et si vous voulez que dans votre
département il y ait des commissariats
rénové si vous vouliez si vous voulez
qu'il y ait des véhicules qui permettent
aux forces de l'ordre de se projeter
dans les quartiers les plus sensibles si
vous vouliez qu'il y ait des moyens de
protection et des armes moderniser il
faut qu'il y ait un effort budgétaire de
fait et cet effort nous le faisons pour
corriger ce que vous avez fait pendant
cinq ans vous avez diminué
considérablement les moyens de la police
et de la gendarmerie
je me rendrai demain monsieur le député
dans le commissariat de creil je me
rendrai pourquoi je me rendrai pour
annoncer les travaux immobiliers qui
vont être faits dans ce commissariat
comme d'ici à la fin du mois de décembre
dans tous les commissariats de france et
y compris à programme monsieur jacob à
votre plus grande satisfaction j'en suis
convaincu vous aurez plaisir à me
accueillir et a constaté que nous
faisons ce que vous n'avez pas fait
deuxièmement nous allons annoncer les
livraisons de matériel à venir au cours
des prochaines semaines et je vais
confirmé qu'en matière de légitime
défense d'anonymisation et de mise à
niveau des pénètre la pénalisation des
insultes à force de l'ordre par rapport
à ce qui se passe pour les magistrats
nous avançons résolument pour les
policiers et les gendarmes de france
merci